hey col O'Brien here coming to you with
another clueless gamer joined as always
by I wouldn't call him a friend an
associate uh Aaron Blair we call him bla
what's happening I'm super excited today
we are going to play Starfield through
this Samsung Neo
qled television with Samsung gaming Hub
you don't need a console all right let's
get into it okay this is your companion
Sarah Morgan so ever since she crash
landed on cpia one it's really been
bothering her but so I can tell her
right now it wasn't your fault I know
but that's not the point is there one
that says fine but first a movie maybe
some wine last thing I want to do is
drag you into some kind of personal
Crusade is there one that says lady drag
away yeah crusade to my
specialty she like that dude I got her
to laugh thanks I really needed a laugh
that's how I've always cracked the ice
my whole life oh hold on a sec when I
set foot on
copia I don't know if I'll be able to
handle what I find it's because I care
what happens to Sarah it's because I
love you look at it parenthesis
flirt please please please
please I don't know what to
say oh I've been so busy searching the
Stars For answers I've overlooked what's
been in front of me all this
time true love something I've seriously
considered sharing with you for a long
time just not
ready not yet when will you be
ready
when
godamn College all over again oh yes not
ready just yet maybe we should go to
like the Las Vegas of space Sarah and I
are now going to hit the club scene this
is fantastic is she running behind me
I'm going to watch her run after me oh
yeah I've done this when women are
jogging I've jogged backwards and looked
at
them not appreciated I don't recommend
it oh yeah look at the they got dancers
there o should I change can I change
clothes he's not going to score in this
thing we can change it to the neon thing
can I just point out there's no bulge oh
yeah do you know what I mean oh yeah
that's true it does go straight down oh
oh oh oh oh my God yeah there's a kind
of that's my body kind of a bulge there
yeah wait how did that looks so much
like my real body sitting down should I
sit next to her I'm giving her a lap
dance in my boxer brief she's getting up
oh she got she disappeared she just
disappeared and walked away is there an
enhancement Zone there it is right there
enhance Perfect all right I'm racing to
enhance all right here we go okay body
type hello hit a hit a yep okay so now
you can move move around a little you
should be able to move the left stick
around oh look oh boy that's not good no
that's terrible
that's terrible I went through that
phase I like that walk that's a cool
walk yeah what's the other
walk you know what I'm gonna take that
walk because he's confident you can also
uh you can change your face here yeah
you can um yeah change your teeth oh my
God he I'm a weatherman look at that
that's incredible forehead let's go
crazy on the forehead and see what
happens
this guy can break through an iceberg
with his
head does she notice the difference ask
her I hope you got something out of that
I just had my whole body and face change
to please you and I see those dead shark
eyes again there are other companions
you know no I have a thing she and I are
in this now and I can't walk away so
there's other companions in this game as
well besides Sarah Morgan there's this
guy named Sam Co and Sam travels around
with his daughter Kora that can be on
your ship and so oh look at this oh
there's a ship with a grandma on it oh
look at that can we blow it
up yeah we can blow or we do you want to
talk to her I want to blow up a grandma
now there's a grandma on this yeah she's
all alone oh by herself I'm just going
to grab a quick nap well granny guess
what never travel alone
bam oh yeah oh no you're locking in on
her oh she's firing back firing backing
back what the hell shooting I am
oh my God this Grandma fired back take
that
Grandma
yes I just BW the grandmother she did
nothing to me but you know what it costs
so much to you know
Elder Care is so
expensive maybe maybe this was a
blessing I'm the worst person alive get
us out of here you can uh go through the
wreckage on her ship and steal it okay
no it's just going to be a lot of yarn
so we're landing on this planet
basically uh Sam CO's ex-wife Lilian is
part of the freest star Rangers I want
to find out what her deal is Sam's had a
lot to say about you and encouraging Sam
with all this constellation is great for
core nonsense it's dangerous so Sam
that's her husband in the back
ex-husband
ex-husband they couldn't make it work
yeah um because she sounds like blanch
du from street car Named Desire when
Sarah meets Lillian is she G to be a
little jealous well Sam really likes you
I think who Sam Sam's Sam is the the
cowb space cowboy do Sam and I have a
relationship you can't if you want well
that's very cool I'm and guess what I'm
okay with that okay great they're going
to attack so you okay go go for it yeah
there you get him yeah why are they
hiding behind
rocks okay that didn't go well let's do
it again I'll get better at this okay
they're all very well oh got him no
there you go don't shoot a naked
guy oh die God the die so skinny and so
naked it's
humiliating I don't think it's me I
think it's this okay do you want to try
another controller yes I do all right
okay great always blame the golf
club why isn't he dead I've hit him like
15 times wait I don't understand I am
it's not firing it's not firing it's not
firing okay it's not firing you put me
out there in my underwear with a gun
that doesn't fire so space is a really
big and weird place and we we've gotten
a distress call from a satellite okay so
oh oh look yeah so let's talk to this
guy here yeah I am Franklin Delano
Roosevelt lead of the pragmatist Society
this is astonishing it's like walking
through some type of Living Museum of
Earth's history I was doing so well with
Sarah and then the longest serving
president in the history of the United
States who got us out of the depression
in one World War II shows
up he's out of the wheelchair how am I
supposed to compete well I got
blocked with Sarah by Franklin Delano
Roosevelt so I don't think I'm going to
get anywhere with her it's time for me
to move on to my next best
option hey thanks for coming here with
me if you need any more support I'm here
yeah I couldn't have done it without you
romance as soon as we met I knew you're
the one for me I love you Sam I'm going
to go for it well I
um you
uh a little lost for words if we do this
I want you to know I want the whole
package candle light dinners walks on
the beach the whole kid and Kaboodle
you you want that too right who the who
was that this is like the biggest woman
in my life who the is
that yes yes I want all of it oh and
you're going to get it I love
you and later on maybe I'll show you
just how
much
I'm in
love I'm with
[Music]
Sam hey Stone Wall I'm in love yes I'm
in love hello pipe I'm in
love yay oh my God you didn't think Sam
loved me well take that there
not I'm in love I've been shot through
the buttock and I'm still in love well I
have to say that was quite a ride we had
some UPS we had some Downs um I pursued
love and then found love uh very excited
about that let's check out Samsung
gaming TVs at
samsung.com gaming TVs or at
participating retailers it's uh it's
pretty cool
yeah I love you
Sam